à quel moment tu t'es dit ça y est je
m'en fous la tâche la met à l'antenne ce
qu'au début tu l'as tu l'as caché
beaucoup bah disons que c'est pas jeu la
cachette on me la faisait cacher
moi au bout d'un moment au bout de six
mois un an je me reconnaissais pas je
vous allez voir Yves Vigo à l'époque en
disant tu sais je me sens pas bien avec
ce maquillage et comme je le dis au
début je me que tu es mon doigt et je
faisais ça sur la tâche parce qu'à
chaque fois on vous met un petit coup de
poudre un petit truc en plus parce que
s'il y a une différence je te rappelle
que à l'époque c'était à l'époque de de
cette année Jean-Luc Delarue que
j'adorais et c'était le genre idéal la
chemise blanche le petit truc aucun
problème il était séducteur et puis de
l'autre côté on avait Christophe
Christophe Dechavanne qui était le
trublion et tout était possible et d'un
seul coup où se placer au milieu de tout
ça je me sentais mal sur ma page je
sentais pas bien et je me disais que
chacun de nous d'entre nous avait vécu
quelque chose à l'école il y avait le
petit il y avait le juif il y avait le
gâteau il y avait le gros il y avait le
maigre il y avait une tache de rousseur
il y avait le rouquin il y avait le
maghrébin il y avait le black il y avait
tout ça et moi j'étais la tâche
et comme on le fait sur les homati ou
dans cette quotidienne des douze coups
de midi on met en avant la différence et
je me suis dit que mais j'étais pas tout
seul que chacun avait sa blessure chacun
avait connu un enfant dans la cour de
récréation on m'appelait nérapé on me
disait mais dis-moi un peu ta mère quand
elle était enceinte elle avait envie de
fraise pour avoir ça sur la tête et j'ai
une petite amie à l'époque c'était une
copine qui m'a dit c'était un passe du
col du Soulor voilà pas juste à côté de
la clinique de l'Union et qui m'a dit je
me rappelle très très bien de son prénom
mais je le dirai pas mais c'était mais
on peut pas sortir ensemble clavier
quand tu as 14 ans et que ton prof de
français te dit à l'école Saint Joseph
la tâche au tableau devant 32 élèves à
partir de ce moment-là je suis allé voir
il Bigot qui est devenu mon pote bien
évidemment et je lui dis tu sais et on
était en 97 sur France 2 c'est le pote
1997 et je lui dis tu sais je me
ressemble pas et quand aujourd'hui il y
a des mecs comme Slimane qui me dit mais
moi aussi on me montrait du doigt sur ma
différence et tu nous as donné de la
force Slimane il était gamin quand
j'étais au début à l'école et il a vu
apparaître il m'a dit j'ai vu apparaître
ta tâche progressivement à l'antenne il
t'a dit quoi il t'a dit vas-y fais comme
tu le sens si tu te sens mieux comme ça
vas-yves tu comprends tu as des pompes
jaunes avec je dis si c'est une question
de couleur j'arrête les pompes jaune et
je laisse la tâche et et j'avais ses
cheveux sur jaune pour un petit clin
d'oreille évidemment un Coluche